[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
regarding Rafiki it was fairly easy
action you know all I really had to do
was put on a little bit of makeup and
let mother nature do its job
[Music]
[Applause]
basically I found the king-sized bed on
the street I took it I dragged it to my
friendly shai's workshop he basically
helps me create all the costumes I do
let's not forget I'm just an idiot on a
skateboard okay he took the fun out of
it carved it and stashed it in order for
it to get this shape or fried Rock all
my costumes
basically are installed on this evolved
electric skateboard which is the only
one that can really handle all the
weight I put on these things
[Music]
the costume is mounted on the skateboard
using hooks they're basically connected
to these ordinary tubes and connectors
[Music]
I was hovering around on my new bus mm
as I saw a police van packed with
officers inside I was nervous for a
slight second until I saw the driver the
cop he was holding the microphone going
like your wizard Harry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]